new allegations emerged that tucker
carlson was caught up in a surveillance
sweep and his emails leaked
the media continued to gaslight
americans over critical race theory and
the left's only remaining political
angle
is apparently january 6th i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first a quick reminder july
4th 1776 we declared our independence
from taxation from a government in ocean
away today
our government is pushing us with
oppressive taxes and they are inflating
the dollar and if you look at the latest
economic reports you will see that there
are some nine million open jobs that are
not being filled thanks to the
government paying people to stay home
all this has a rather deleterious effect
on your savings which is just one reason
why you should diversify at least a
little bit
into gold or silver if you haven't
reached out to birch gold diversify part
of your ira or 401k into a precious
metals ira
do it today text ben 47 47 47 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings
with gold i buy my gold from birch gold
they have an a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless 5 star
reviews
over 10 000 happy customers talk to them
have them help you safeguard
your investments text ben to 47 47 47 to
claim your free information kit and
speak with a precious metals expert on
holding gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account again you owe it to
yourself to at least ask all the
questions and get all the answers you
need with regard to investing in
precious metals and then
diversify at least a little bit into an
asset that has never been worth zero
again text ben
to 47 47 47 protect your savings
today alrighty so big story of the day
is that tucker carlson claimed you'll
recall about a week ago
that the nsa had been spying on his
emails that they had been looking into
his emails and his communications
and that he had heard from somebody
inside the nsa that the nsa
had gotten control of these things and
that they were going to leak them to the
press
now two things can be true at once one
tucker carlson could have been caught up
in some sort of
surveillance sweep to target american
citizens the nsa
has to essentially catch you up
in a sweep with foreign citizens so for
example we're monitoring some sort of
spy from russia and that person talks
with an american
and we end up picking up the americans
communications because we're monitoring
the spy from russia for example
but to specifically target an american
citizen you require a fisa
surveillance warrant you have to go to a
fisa court now
can that be gamed absolutely that's
exactly what happened with carter page
the department of justice put forward a
bad fisa warrant against carter page and
then proceeded to
basically monitor all of his
communications and surveil him despite
the fact that there was no real evidence
that he was a russian asset
at all so it's certainly possible what
appears to have happened in this
particular
case with tucker is the two simultaneous
things one that they were monitoring
foreign
intelligence officers or foreign uh
foreign threats supposedly
and those people were apparently
speaking to tucker this is what they are
claiming
and two the actual crime is if somebody
leaks that material
so this raises a couple questions one
are we too broadly
construing the surveillance statutes the
answer here is yes
in order to catch up prominent people
and then you'd have to unmask the people
because typically
in order to find out who the american
citizen is on the other side of the line
you have to go through what's called the
unmasking process
and this is supposed to facilitate
national security but as we saw
with regard to susan rice and the obama
administration in the last days of the
obama administration
they were unmasking people like michael
flynn specifically because they wanted
to do political damage is what it looks
like
so it looks like there are two separate
things that could have been happening
here one
surveillance of tucker sort of by way of
accidents is what they are going to
claim but then you have to question
given their
prior record whether that is an accident
and two the actual leaking of the
material because tucker is suggesting
not just that the nsa caught him up in
some sort of surveillance sweep
but that his emails are going to be
leaked to the press hey this is a
deep and devastating criminal activity
when you have members of the so-called
deep state when you have members of the
intelligence community the deep state
and i'm not talking about some giant
conspiracy deep state what i'm talking
about here
is people who are career bureaucrats who
exist inside an area of the american
government where there is no
effective turnover when those people
decide that they're going to
abuse their power by getting access to
private information and then blowing
that out in public
that is a crime and the fact that we've
been unable to track down people who
have been leaking classified information
about their fellow american citizens to
the general public just demonstrates
once again why people have
very little trust in our nation's
institutions okay all of this came to a
head yesterday when axios reported on it
axios reports tucker carlson was talking
to us-based kremlin intermediaries about
setting up an interview with vladimir
putin shortly before
the fox news host accused the nsa of
spying on him sources familiar with the
conversations
tell axios those sources said u.s
government officials learned about
carlson's efforts to secure the putin
interview
carlson learned that the government was
aware of his outreach and that's the
basis of his extraordinary accusation
followed by a rare public denial by the
nsa that he had been targeted now
remember
when the nsa said he wasn't targeted
that doesn't mean they didn't catch him
up in a surveillance sweep
and if they actually have people there
who are leaking his personal information
that is a separate crime and a separate
issue axios has not confirmed at this
point whether any communications from
carlson have been intercepted
and if so why and this is a really big
problem okay because
why exactly would tucker be caught up in
some sort of surveillance
sweep with regard to attempting to
broker an interview
with vladimir putin vladimir putin did a
sit-down interview with nbc news like a
month ago
were the nbc news anchors caught up in
the surveillance week
were the nbc news producers caught up in
their surveillance sweep we have no
evidence that they were
and certainly nothing that they said was
in danger of being leaked to the media
there are deep connections in washington
dc between the media and the democratic
party and the democratic party
overwhelmingly dominates the
bureaucratic halls of power
and so you do have this democratic media
complex where information is
laundered out into the public via
intelligence apparatuses
and pushed into the media right we saw
this with the steele dossier for example
which was leaked out
from the federal government to sources
in the media who then just blasted it
out you'll remember
that buzzfeed news just blasted out the
entire steele dossier
without check fact checking any of the
claims suggesting that it was noteworthy
specifically because james comey
met with president trump and gave him a
copy of the steele dossier this quote
unquote made it newsworthy and then
allowed buzzfeed to simply blast out the
allegations which became
the cause of the left for a nia for for
essentially four years
now people are left still claiming that
the steele dossier was filled
with unspoken truths or now spoken
truths
according to axios carlson told his
roughly 3 million viewers on june 28th
that the day before he had heard from a
whistleblower within the us government
who reached out to warn us that the nsa
is monitoring our electronic
communications and is planning to leak
them in an attempt to take the show
off the air carlson said that his source
was in a position to know repeated back
to us information about a story we are
working on
that could have only come directly from
my texts and emails
carlson said it's illegal for the nsa to
spy on american citizens things like
that should not happen in america
unfortunately they do happen and in this
case they did happen the nsa said that
his allegation is untrue the question is
which allegation because tucker
he's actually wrapping up a few
allegations there one is that he was
caught up and that they were monitoring
his communications
and the other is that they were
specifically targeting his
communications and not quite the same
thing
one is legal one is illegal but the leak
is certainly illegal
a fox news spokesperson said we support
any of our hosts pursuing interviews and
stories free
of government interference carlson said
as i've said repeatedly because it's
true
the nsa read my emails and then leaked
their contents that's an outrage as well
as
it's unclear why carlson or his source
as axios would think that this outreach
could be the basis for nsa surveillance
or a motive to have his show cancelled
journalists routinely reach out to world
leaders for request interviews
and numerous american journalists have
interviewed putin in recent years
chris wallace earned fox news his first
emmy nomination for its 2018
putin interview carlson told mario
bartoromo his executive producer knew
about the communications
in question those were the that was the
only other person he didn't mention
anybody else
including his wife and the nsa's public
statement did not deny directly that any
carlson communications had been swept up
by the agency axios has now submitted a
request for comment to the nsa on
wednesday asking whether the agency
would also be willing to categorically
deny that the nsa intercepted any of
carlson's communications
in the context of monitoring somebody he
was talking to in his efforts to set up
an interview with putin
an nsa spokesperson declined to comment
referred axios back to the agency's
earlier
carefully worded statement in other
words the nsa is denying the targeting
of carlson but is not denying that his
communications were incidentally
collected
so what exactly happens next according
to axios the first and least likely
scenario is the us government submitted
a request
to a fisa court to monitor carlson more
plausible scenario is one of the people
carlson was talking to
as an intermediary was under
surveillance and then carlson was caught
up in that
in that scenario carlson's emails or
text messages could have been
incidentally collected
as part of monitoring that person but
carlson's identity would then have been
masked
so in order to know that text and emails
were carlson's a us government source
would have to unmask
carlson and that is only necessary if
the unmasking
is required to understand the
intelligence
so two sources familiar with carlson's
communications said his two kremlin
intermediaries live in the u.s
the sources could not confirm whether
both are american citizens or whether
both
were on u.s soil at the time they
communicated with carlson which is
relevant
because if one was a foreign national in
on foreign soil during the
communications the us government would
wouldn't have necessarily have had to
seek approval to monitor
those communications here's the bottom
line we haven't seen what exactly
is tucker is suggesting is going to be
leaked out here but if there is a leak
from the intelligence apparatus about
tucker carlson's emails
that is a crime and it would not be the
only crime committed during the
biden tenure or frankly during the trump
tenure
the the obama administration was
notoriously non-leaky there were not of
lee not a lot of leaks
coming out of the obama administration
why because the bureaucracy favored
obama but there are tons of leaks during
the trump administration targeting trump
officials targeting trump himself we
routinely saw information that the
american public really does not have a
quote unquote right to see because
they're private communications
we saw all of that stuff coming out
routinely during the trump
administration and
post-trump we've seen more of that
you'll recall that just a few weeks ago
the entire
media decided it would be worthwhile to
blast out the propublica report
about the tax returns of people like
jeff bezos
now none of that is obtained legally it
is illegal
to leak somebody's tax records from the
irs
in fact merrick garland the attorney
general of the united states last month
he said that he was going to track down
who had who had committed those leaks we
have yet to hear any follow-up on this
particular issue
to be honest i know nothing more than
about this than what i read
in the pro-publica piece which i also
read and was astonished
now what i did read in that piece was
that the ir uh
the um director of the irs is on it
and uh he said that their inspectors um
were working on it and i'm sure that
that means it will be referred to the
justice department and when i this was
on my list of things
to raise after i finished preparing for
this hearing
and i promise you will be at the top of
my list
we will see we will see you know count
me a little bit skeptical
because it turns out that again the
intelligence apparatus in the
bureaucracy
is leaking and they are leaking almost
solely with regard to people on one side
of the political aisle when you
weaponize
the the parts of the american government
that are not subject to public approval
right you can't unelect the bureaucrat
and you have to rely on people like
merrick garland to ferret them out
and and fire them even the trump
administration was not fully able to do
that
you remember that the trump
administration got itself in all sorts
of trouble because they were doing leak
investigations on house democrats in the
media specifically because they were
trying to find out
who inside these these in
the administration who inside the
bureaucracy was leaking information
about for example the mueller
investigation to the media and remember
those leaks were constant many of them
were untrue
you saw that information coming
constantly from the bureaucracy well
when the bureaucracy has the media on
speeds aisle
your privacy does not count anymore and
then you wonder why people don't trust
the institutions of the american
government
why they don't believe that these
institutions are neutral in any
particular way
the tucker story is a good indicator of
why people don't feel that those
institutions
are neutral right if tucker carlson even
if he was legally caught up in some sort
of sweep
if that information is leaked out to the
media that is a
massive scandal and it should be a
massive scandal because it means they
can do it to you
it means that any time they find
somebody who's politically unpalatable
and they catch them up in some sort of
intelligence sweep they can unmask that
person
and then they can just reveal that
information to
a general public anytime they want which
means
that you can't trust that any of your
information is safe
at all it means that unless you are
using some sort of vbn or unless you are
using a special email
service all that information can be
gathered pretty easily by the government
the government frankly can subpoena much
of it
and then members of the government can
leak that information out about you so
whether you like tucker
you know there are a lot of folks on the
show who are tucker fans a lot of folks
listen to the show who are
not tucker fans whether you like or just
like tucker is completely aside from the
point
the point is that when you have a
bureaucracy that is specifically
able to without any real fear leak out
private information of american citizens
to harm them politically
you're living and that that is an aspect
of totalitarianism
it is an attempt by the powers that be
to destroy people that they oppose
at any particular time and there is no
answerability and no accountability
alrighty coming up in just one second
we're going to talk
about the the left's view that true
patriotism is apparently anti-patriotism
this
is their their continued push for
critical race theory and how they would
really like to indoctrinate your
children they're becoming clearer and
clearer about this and it is quite ugly
first let us talk about keeping your
home safe there are thousands of reasons
why protecting my home matters to me if
somebody stops by or something is going
on outdoors around the house
ring will let me know it's peace of mind
any time knowing my home is protected at
my house i can keep an eye on every
corner of the house with rings
easy to install indoor and outdoor cams
to get ring alarm for yourself
go to ring.com ben that's ring.com
forward slash pen it's the perfect way
to start your ring experience besides
ring being a powerful asset for my home
ring is also an affordable home home
security system you can easily install
yourself and it's never been more
important to be able to see who's there
or what's happening anytime around the
house inside
or outside i can see it all in one
simple app that's right with ring
my family and i can keep an eye on our
home no matter where we are right from
our phone
it's great to know you're not going to
miss a visitor with rings hassle free
easy to install indoor and outdoor cams
and know when those packages are
delivered start protecting your home
today with ring alarm go to ring.com get
your ring alarm security kit today you
can build the system that's right for
your home
have it up and running in minutes that
is ring.com ben again
ring.com ben go check them out right now
ring.com to get your ring alarm
security kit today alrighty so
meanwhile the the left has increasingly
seated
the notion of patriotism to the right
and they're starting to realize that
this is a problem
so much of what they're indoctrinating
our children into in the public schools
is a notion that america is at baseline
at root a very very bad place and as
corey bush says a place
uh built upon stolen land and if by this
she means that the united states was
built on military
conquest and settling that is true for
literally every civilization in the
history of mankind
it's just that the united
inhabitants of the st states from europe
uh were
were more had a higher ability to occupy
land
and dispossess the people who were on it
uh than other people who had previously
existed on the continent
but the notion that the united states is
uniquely bad in world history is of
course
belied by the reality of what the united
states has been namely a nation that
sacrificed hundreds of thousands of
people to and slavery
a nation that freed europe multiple
times that defeated communism
that made itself the most racially
tolerant place on planet earth literally
there is no more racially tolerant place
than the united states on planet earth
and yet the notion of the left is that
true patriotism is anti-patriotism we
saw this
a lot during the bush administration
descent is the highest form of
patriotism is what you current
you constantly heard well depends on
what the nature of the dissent is
because if you descend from the idea
that america is good that is not in fact
the highest form
of patriotism but the left seems to be
ceding root
baseline patriotism to the right which
is a hell of a political move
so for example over the weekend cnn made
the argument that flying the american
flag
is increasingly seen as a republican
symbol the question is why you guys are
doing that
i mean really joe biden doesn't want to
do that if you look at joe biden's july
4th speech it is old-style democratic
speech-making in which you talked about
the glories of america and the wonders
of the flag
and the greatness of july 4th but the
democratic party increasingly is
uncomfortable they're in a post-american
moment they don't believe that america
is good
and so they're increasingly seeding all
of the symbols of some of
american patriotism to the right which
is a really stupid move
here was cnn discussing it i wanted to
see what you both think about a
an article in the new york times that
has garnered a lot of attention titled a
fourth of july symbol of unity
that may no longer unite this is about
of course the american flag and the
author writes today flying the flag from
the back of a pickup truck
or over a lawn is increasingly seen as a
clue albeit an imperfect one to a
person's
political affiliation in a deeply
divided
nation uh the idea here and there are
moments that are documented in this
story
of people liberals making an assumption
seeing an american flag that maybe the
person flying it
is actually a trump supporter or is a
conservative
okay so again this generalized point
that the american flag is bad
right is is backed up by the fact you
have players
in multiple sports who are now
celebrated for kneeling for the american
flag or kneeling for the national anthem
now that's a weird move but this is the
move that the democrats are increasingly
making the highest form of patriotism is
to suggest that america is terrible and
needs to be fundamentally changed and
the best way of fundamentally changing
america is of course to indoctrinate
your children
the best way to change the future of the
united states is to take control of the
education
of your kids and this has been going on
as we've been discussing at length on
the show with regard to things like race
or or sexual politics it's been going on
in the public schools for decades on end
at this point and now that the left is
is finally being exposed for what it is
with regard to the public schools
their simple move is just to deny so
nicole wallace for example head on randy
weingarten of the american federation of
teachers who has said
the american federation of teachers by
the way recently was
openly pre i mean they they literally
had an event in which ibrahim's candy
appeared last night
okay so they're very much in favor of
the quote-unquote anti-racist movement
which is an outgrowth of critical
critical race theory
and is an outgrowth of the idea that
america is inherently bad and that
america
is imbued with whiteness and that the
only way to overcome that whiteness is
to destroy the institutions
here is nicole wallace trying to
soft-pedal critical race theory because
again our media are invested in this
sort of stuff
you tweeted this critical race theory is
not taught in k-12 schools
the rights cultural warriors are
labeling any discussion of race racism
or discrimination as such to try to make
it toxic
we've talked about teachers getting
bullied we've talked about the chaos
what about the kids i mean i i you know
i i think it's a very scary prospect
we look to our the next generation to
sort of
evolve in a way that gets us out of the
current morass the most
frightening thing to me about the
cultural war moving into this space is
the damage it could do to our kids
yes the culture war is going to damage
our kids says nicole wallace it was fine
when when
randy weingarten and company were
indoctrinating our kids it's when people
start to push back that we've got a
problem
speaking of which i mean randy
weingarten is
she's denying that the american
federation of teachers is teaching
critical race theory
meanwhile they literally had ibrahim x
kendy
the great race drifter of the country
right now speak
to an aft conference yesterday yesterday
in which he he said this quote to be
anti-racist is to admit the times which
were being
racist he said to be racist is to
constantly consistently deny deny deny
like donald trump kennedy said in
studying the history of racism even
studying the history of times in which
people were being racist
what i found was a consistent sort of
narrative was just denial was people
denying the ways in which they were
being racist the racist policies they're
racist ideas see right now if you say
that you're not a racist it's because
you're actually a racist
there's a basic kafka trap then kenny
suggested that critical race theory is
not being taught
in k-12 schools but
of course that is not true critical race
theory is lies at the root of
virtually all of whiteness studies and
lies at the root of the anti-racism
studies
in the same way that intersectionality
started off as like a small legal
article by
kimberly crenshaw and then quickly
became an ideology that spread
throughout the nation
this is what happens in academia right
there they're very
sort of nuanced and complex but radical
arguments made in academia they're
simplified and they're blasted out
to the entire population via a wide
variety of outlets
and that's how you end up with crt being
taught to our kids and the media want to
defend this stuff
right the media are interested in the
idea that it is an active good
to indoctrinate your kids in in
non-traditional
modes of americanism right so for
example cnn yesterday
they're again their constant move is the
reason that you're bucking against
critical race theory in public schools
the reason that you're upset with all of
this
is because you don't understand that
true patriotism requires us to
indoctrinate your children
and you don't understand the
indoctrination right the big problem is
you don't understand critical race
theory
right this is this is the the no true
scotsman fallacy nothing is critical
race theory according to the left
if you say richard delgado and gene
stefancek argue specific premises
they'll say well that even that is not
critical race theory you just don't
understand it
no we understand it it's real bad but
here is cnn trying to pretend they're
gaslighting you you don't know what
critical race theory is so why would you
oppose it
cnn's ellie reeves spoke with a teacher
who uses critical race theory
and looked at how backlash to this
framework has exploded
so ellie do these vocal opponents of
critical race theory
actually understand fully what it is no
critical race theory is an academic
framework that says racial inequality is
perpetuated by the racism embedded in
america's laws
not by individual bigotry but relentless
propaganda from some conservatives has
created a panic that white people
and especially white children are under
attack
okay except the critical race theory
explicitly says that if you are white
you benefit
from those systems regardless of whether
you think you do or whether you're
racist you benefit from those systems so
you have to separate from your own
whiteness okay this is a part of
critical race theory
okay so again the goal here from the
media from much of the left
is to dissociate from traditional
symbols of american unity or traditional
ideas that undergird american unity
and to indoctrinate kids i mean there's
just no question that this is
happening right now unfortunately the
the indoctrination of kids that is now
the purview of the left right the left
believes again that fundamental american
principles that are taught in the home
or fundamental traditional principles
about about religion or god or
traditional sexual mores or individual
rights all that stuff
has to be taught out of our kids as you
heard right there nicole wallace say the
dangerous thing
is if parents would be allowed to parent
their children in accordance with those
old values
we have to allow the children to evolve
it's important
for the children to evolve and every so
often you see you know some pretty solid
evidence
that folks on the radical left this is
their intent they're not really hiding
it
in california as i mentioned yesterday
on the show it is written in law that
kids
kindergarten through sex are now going
to be taught effectively lgbtq
propaganda
and that is not being done specifically
for
for any other reason they say that it's
about the quote unquote safety of kids
it is not about the safety of kids
there are ways to protect kids from
bullying that do not involve teaching
lgbtq
radical propaganda that is not what the
goal here is the goal instead is to
change the mindset and the sexual
behavior
or interests or confusion of small
children that's the only reason why you
would teach this crap to kindergarteners
you don't have to do any of that stop
bullying if you have a neutral law about
bullying
in in schools if you have neutral rules
about bullying in schools
that is good enough and that applies to
everybody regardless of how those kids
act in the classroom
but once you start teaching kids about
gender fluidity that can only
be an attempt to indoctrinate them in a
particular way of viewing the world and
to confuse them about behavior that is
all that that can be okay so there was a
video that came out yesterday
or it would come out i guess a few days
ago and it was taken down yesterday
from the san francisco gay men's square
it kind of went viral on the right
folks on the left were claiming that it
was a parody the question is what
exactly is it a parody of
so here is the san francisco gay men's
choir they released this on youtube
they did a video titled we are coming
for your children
they say that it was tongue-in-cheek
humor but
the problem is that the statement that
they released uh doesn't really
suggest that it is fully tongue-in-cheek
here's a little bit of the video
you think that we'll corrupt your kids
if our agenda goes unchecked
it's funny just this once you're correct
we'll convert your children
happens bit by bit quietly and subtly
and you will barely notice it we're
coming
for your children
we're coming for your children we'll
convert them bit by bit
very solid stuff there in this song
we'll convert your children yes we will
reaching one and all there's really no
escaping it because even grandma likes
rupaul
the world is getting kinder gen z is
gayer than grinder we're coming for them
we're coming for your children the gay
agenda is coming home
the gay agenda is here okay so if this
is tongue-in-cheek like we're really not
coming from your children right it's
tongue-in-cheek it's
it's periodical then why would the san
francisco gay men's choir release the
following statement this is their
statement
claiming that everybody's taking this
too seriously quote the negative even
threatening responses prove that this
music and our mission are critically
necessary in today's world
many children are not being taught the
truth our message to you from the gay
community
we will continue to do our best to
counter the message of hate by teaching
young people to be tolerant and fair
it is obvious the tongue-in-cheek humor
is lost on many especially the ones
spewing death threats please take a
moment and read the entire text
we'll make an ally of you yet we are
proud of who we are we are proud of what
we sing okay
the key sentence there is our message to
you from the gay community we'll
continue to do our best to counter the
message of hate by teaching young people
to be tolerant and fair so basically
what you're saying is that the the song
is not actually a parody what you're
actually suggesting
is that while the song is done in the
mode of parody the underlying message
which is that we wish to teach your
children our values
that part is is correct right we are
making your kids more tolerant and fair
by teaching them what we want to teach
them in schools now you as a parent may
object to this
you as a parent may say listen i wish to
teach my kids traditional sexual values
and mores i don't want my cannot forget
any of that i don't want my kids
like k through six i don't i don't
believe that it's appropriate
for kids who are five years old to have
to be taught
about a wide variety of gender fluidity
and sexual orientation questions
it's it's confusing it opposes natural
law in in this sort of traditional
moralistic sense but also in the logical
sense the the the notion
the notion of gender fluidity opposes
biology itself
like i don't think that any of this is
appropriate to be taught to children i
forgot regardless of political
view it's just not appropriate for kids
but the idea here is that we are going
to change the next generation
right this is why for example there's an
entire article
recently in indy wire i think talking
about how
children's animated shows were now being
stacked with
radical lgbtq propaganda content
bisexual characters and children's
animated shows gender fluid characters
transgender characters
in shows made for five and six years
olds five five and six year olds
right so the left has a very different
vision of what america the radical left
has a very different vision of what
america ought to be
and the way that they are going to
achieve this is by changing
how your kids are are taught and if you
push back on them then this of course
makes you the true threat to the kids
this makes you the this again you want
to
separate the country this is the easiest
way of separating the country
because as i say i'm going to educate my
kids help i want to educate my kids
and frankly i am not interested in what
the san francisco gay men's choir thinks
my kids should learn i i don't really
care they are not the parents of my kids
they don't know my kid's name
and they don't want what's best for my
kids i want what's best for my kids
and i get to decide that cause i'm the
parent the same thing holds true for
randy weingarten in the american
federation of teachers it holds true for
the national
education association it holds truth for
joe biden it holds true for all these
members of government
i get to decide how i want to teach my
kids and what i would like to teach my
kids as it turns out
is a traditional sexual morality and
traditional individual
rights view of how the government should
work with regards both race and sex
that's what i'd like to teach my kids
and if you got a problem with that
frankly you can stick it
so here's the thing a lot of this agenda
is deeply unpopular
and folks on the left know it's deeply
unpopular and so they are left with
basically one club left
they are left with one club and that
club that they've been using and they're
using it over and over these days is
january 6th
they're relying more and more heavily on
it look at how many times democrats
mentioned january 6. it's day
in and day out all the time we're gonna
get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
simple fact
that you do not need to go to the auto
parts store who would want to go to the
auto parts store you're standing in line
you're waiting there finally you get to
the front of the line and then when you
do
get to the front of the line they ask
you a bunch of questions about your car
you have to look it up
you get the part and then they're like
oh yeah we're ordering it and we're up
charging you by 30
or you could just go online and do it
yourself this is what rockauto.com does
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
well i spend up to twice as much for the
same parts they are a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is unique
and remarkably easy to navigate quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck right
shapiro and
how did you hear about usbox so they
know that we sent you again that is
rockauto.com
go check them out right now that is
right now and make sure that you say
that the show sent you
when you go to the the how did you hear
about xbox best parts
best price rockauto.com all right we'll
get to
more in just one second first michael
knowles as you know has a new book out
this one has words in it the book is
called speechless controlling words
controlling minds if you haven't picked
up a copy now is the time to do it tens
of thousands of you already have
the book takes you through the origins
of pc and what it's rapid spread through
american society it means for our future
it'll give you the tools you need to
understand and spot political
correctness in order to stop it
uh now here's the thing noel's book was
the number one nonfiction bestseller
in the country going into july 4th
according to publishers weekly
and sold like 20 000 copies in the first
week of release
it did not even make the new york times
list because the new york times is a
garbage organization and their list is
politically skewed
just going to show exactly what he says
that if you cross the politically
correct
bosses they will silence you if you
don't know the history and relevance of
pc already you're about to
go do everyone a favor pick up a copy of
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it's available everywhere right
now if you don't feel like making a trip
it's available on amazon in hardcover
and kindle edition as well you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so just a quick final note when it comes
to the
indoctrination of the kids again
there's there's no bones being made
about this the nea the single largest
teachers union in the country
recently passed a resolution pledging to
share and publicize information
available on critical race theory
welcome
while claiming that they're not teaching
critical race theory they
openly say that they want to provide an
already created in-depth study that
critiques empire white supremacy
anti-blackness
anti-indigeneity racism patriarchy cis
heteropatriarchy capitalism ableism
anthropocentrism and other forms of
power and oppression at the
intersections
of our society okay
when when i say that they are coming to
indoctrinate your kids it is because
they believe
quite correctly that how kids are
educated when they are young makes a
difference in how they grow up and what
values they hold
and so they are attempting the radical
left is to grab controls of your kids
education
and then never to seed them to you again
now there are some people on the right
who seem to believe that the way that
you fight this
is quote unquote competition in the
marketplace of ideas when you're talking
about public schools where the curricula
are established by the nea
and the aft in coordination with state
legislators this is not an option this
is a zero-sum game
somebody is going to decide the
standards is it going to be you or is it
going to be a bunch of radical left
theorists who have decided that your
kids are going to be tools
in their attempt to evolve society
toward the views they like
and it was really interesting i
mentioned it before there was an article
in the new york times
in which they suggested and when i say
they i mean a variety of authors
including a bunch of authors that i
generally like
suggested that it's un-american for
state legislatures to try and ban
critical race theory
they argue in the article that the
educational mission is
to help student turn students into
well-informed and discerning
citizens and they say that this is
undermined by restrictions banning the
the teaching of critical race theory so
first of all that ignores what critical
race theory is it is an activist
ideology openly a critical race theory
says what it is
the same thing is true with regard to
teaching lgbtq plus ideology in schools
it is an activist ideology directed at
changing traditional mores and standards
that's what it is
people don't make any bones about this
second of all when we say
that education is designed to help turn
students into well-informed and
discerning
citizens the word citizen doesn't just
mean people citizens has an actual
definition
the aristotelian definition of a good
citizen is a person
who upholds the constitution of his
particular apollos meaning
political body if you teach
your your kids to be bad citizens in the
aristotelian sense
bucking against all of the systems
bucking against all of the traditions
and values
of the systems you're not teaching your
kid to be a good citizen you're teaching
your kids to be a bad citizen
and you end up as a country with no
future okay so again i think that
most americans are beginning to wake up
to this and the left is beginning to
realize it and they're running a little
bit scared
because of it and so you're suddenly
seeing this upswell
of articles from the new york times it
really is amazing in which they are
openly defending
the indoctrination of students into
radical creeds there's an article in the
new york times
today titled a private school sex
educator defends
her methods after nine years at dalton
why was justine
and fonte suddenly being pilloried by
parents
the articles by valeria safranova quote
sex education is a sensitive subject
but during nine years at the prestigious
dalton school on the upper east side of
manhattan
seven of which she spent as the director
of health and wellness justine ang fond
seemed to be handling it with success
she developed curriculums for students
from kindergarten through 12th grade
hired three other health educators in
organized documentary viewings
discussions and workshops for parents
she was also a regular speaker at
educational forums like the national
association of independent schools
people of color conference and offered
workshops and presentations at other new
york city schools
one of these was columbia grammar and
prep school on the upper west side
which in may invited her to teach two
zoom sessions on pornography literacy
and consent
to its juniors and seniors bill donahue
the head of schools there said
quote there may have been confusion on
our part about which course we would
receive
a couple of parents complained afterward
but there had been 120 students many of
whom gave her great feedback she didn't
dwell on it
about a week later she woke up to find
herself featured in the new york post
quote students and parents real after
class on porn
literacy dalton parents enraged over
masturbation videos for first graders
the articles included screenshots from
miss fancy's lesson a possibility
in the zoom classroom world versions of
the articles appeared in the sun the
daily mail and on fox news
fonte then resigned multiple sex
educators interviewed for this article
said there was nothing inappropriate
about her classes there or
at columbia it was all in line with the
current national sex education standards
and the who's international technical
guidance
on sexuality education the national
standards are also used
in public schools in new york city where
students in grades 6 through 12 take
lessons on sexuality
as part of their health education the
material for first graders
never used the term masturbation fonte
said recently the lesson was about two
private
was about private parts being private
and included a cartoon in which two
characters used anatomically correct
names for their genitals and say that
sometimes it feels good to touch them
quote it is okay to touch yourself and
see how different body parts feel but
it's best to only do it in private the
narrator tells the viewers
or kids between the ages of five and but
says the new york times the who
is fine with this stuff the who likes it
so you should like it
as a parent and well again this sort of
crap
it turns out parents don't like it and
so the left is reeling because on
culture issues this is the thing
trump was elected because of culture
issues he was not elected because of
economic issues
people seem to be of the opinion in the
elite world and this is true right and
left that trump was elected because of
his economic agenda which was tariff
focused
or is focused on on raising taxes on
particular
parts of the population and was economic
nationalist and
and was rooted in subsidies to blue
collar workers and all this kind of
stuff
that is not correct the reason that
trump won is because the left has been
declaring an open culture war on the
rest of the united states since 2010
approximately
it's been accelerating radically since
then and people are pushing back against
it
and now members of the left are
beginning to realize that this is bad
politics
they're starting to real they don't want
to say it because again that would
undercut their evolutionary notions of
how morality ought to
ought to change over time but instead
they are pushing back the way they are
pushing back is chiefly with january 6th
they understand left us that what they
are promoting
generally speaking is not in line with
traditional motions of patriotism
you know yelling about the american flag
and the national anthem
suggesting that motherhood is not a
thing because after all they're just
birthing people
suggesting that there is no such thing
as a traditional sexual value to be held
in the united states and if you do
you're a bigot
undermining religion and freedom of
speech these are not things most
americans are on board with
and to the left has to they they don't
really want to cede
the patriotic in the united states
instead they would like to redefine
patriotism to apply to an agenda
that is explicitly anti traditional
notions of what it meant to be american
and rooted in individual rights rooted
in freedom but also rooted in in a
certain sense of responsibility and
virtue
they want to they would like to simply
redefine patriotism to not mean that so
the best
tool they have to do this is to point it
january 6th because january 6th
was an incident in which people who were
purportedly right-wing when i say
purportedly right-wing
i don't mean that they were left-wing
they weren't what i mean is that they
were not conservative in any traditional
sense or libertarian in any traditional
sense
it turns out that storming the capitol
building is neither a conservative nor a
libertarian
position what the left would like to do
is suggest that it is a conservative
libertarian position
therefore the true people who hate the
country the true people who are
anti-patriotic the true people seeking
to undermine
america are not people who are radically
indoctrinating your children with
theories that are completely foreign to
the founding of the united states
the people who are really seeking to
undermine america are right-wingers
this has been the goal since since
january 6th
january 6th was an act of of evil by a
bunch of
idiot droogs who decided to run into the
capitol building for no discernible
purpose
other than to do harm to people and
property and act like generalized idiots
okay that's what january 6th was nobody
ripped it harder than i did
it was really bad you know what is even
worse for the country and a bunch of
droogs
running into a government building and
then them being cleared out of the
government building most of them being
arrested
and government going about its business
within two hours you know what's worse
than that
the complete reshaping of american
politics to suggest that anyone
who is conservative or voted for trump
is complicit in that sort of activity
and hates the country and is
anti-patriotic and that's precisely what
the media are doing so at the same time
that the media are celebrating people
who kneel for the flag the media is
suggesting
that you traditional conservative who
likes the flag you traditional
libertarian who believes in individual
rights
you're complicit in january 6th by dint
of association
right you may have voted for trump trump
was saying stuff that wasn't true about
about the election people who believe
that stuff went in and did something bad
on january 6
because of that chain of association you
are responsible conservatism is
anti-american
this is the goal of the media because
this is the only pushback they've got
which is why you saw chris cuomo for
example out there on cnn suggesting
that connecting celebration of july 4th
to january 6th
people who are flag wavers many of those
same flag wipers waivers celebrated
january 6. they're the true
anti-patriots
i must remind you tonight that we are
marking
six months since january 6th i know a
lot of you are going to roll your eyes
do me a favor roll them but keep them
open
all right because on that day many who
celebrated this weekend saying they love
this country
try to destroy it
and they're going to keep focusing on
january 6th because this is the only
example they can point to
of people who are purportedly right wing
or trump associated
doing something bad and violent right
this is this is their big example and
it's a great example of people doing
something bad and violent the images are
stunning
they're attacks on police officers
obviously right all of that
happens to be true the part that's not
true is that everybody who supported
trump was in league with this or
approves of this
but again they keep trying to broaden
out january 6th because if you just
treat january 6th
as what it was an isolated incident in
which
a bunch of idiots several hundred morons
decided to invade a government building
and the security was improper if if
that's
what it boils down to as opposed to a
broad-based movement to overthrow the
american government
then why are we still talking about it
it turns out that a much broader
movement involving violence
happened last year and has now been
deeply embedded in every institution of
our society to the point where you have
to mirror all of its priorities or you
will be ousted from public life
namely the black lives matter movement
which was linked to at least two billion
dollars in insurable property damage
probably
it's double that because a lot of that
property wasn't insured and linked to
many deaths by the way
okay so but the media have to the media
must continue to focus on this and
broaden it out which is why you have an
article
called a horn wearing shaman a cowboy
evangelist for some
the capital attack was a kind of
christian revolt now the suggestion
of that title for michelle borstein the
the suggestion of the
of the very title is that christianity
is inherently
intertwined with january 6 january 6 bad
therefore christianity bad how do we
know this because we found three people
who say that they were christian who
engaged in this activity or cited their
christianity as motivating factor
out of hundreds of people and those
people are are a mere subset
of the hundreds of millions of americans
who count themselves
as christian but christianity is bad
and january 6th is bad and therefore
it's all the same
and the maximization of january 6 has
become a key
a a very very key piece of the
democratic agenda if they can distract
with january 6
if they can continue to shout about
january 6th and maybe you won't pay
attention to the stuff that's actually
happening at your local school board
level maybe you'll ignore the fact that
the
radical left at the congressional level
is attempting to rewrite the laws
by about how voting is done maybe you'll
ignore the fact that joe biden is
explicitly attempting to override
notions of individual rights and
equality before law
in favor of a broader equity agenda that
adjudicates
based on racial group maybe you'll
ignore all of that
if we can just say that everyone who
disagrees with joe biden or disagrees
with the washington post or disagrees
with the new york times
is somehow complicit in january 6th
and so every story becomes a major story
for example the daily beast yesterday
reported that a a one of the january
sixth
rioters uh was when he was arrested the
fbi seized a
fully constructed u.s capital lego set
from his home
according to the pittsburgh post gazette
robert morris a substitute social
studies teacher allegedly engaged in
violent behavior
video shows him near the front line of
the riders who pushed past police
guarding the capitol
organizing a shield wall in the attack
on officers in the lower west terrace
tunnel and then entering the building
through a broken window
in court documents apparently the the
doj pushed for morris to be detained
until trial
and the federal government said during
his arrest law enforcement recovered
some clothing
and other items that appear to match
those he carried with him on the sixth
including his own tread on me flag a
neck gator a military utility bag a
black tourniquet
and military fatigues also law
enforcement recovered a fully
constructed us capital lego set
wow and wait until they invade my house
and
they find out that my son has a fully
assembled
death star model listen it's fine you
want to come with evidence of people who
are writers they can
go to jail fine with me but i think
you're gonna have a hard time saying
that it holds up in court
uh that his beautifully constructed u.s
capital lego set
was the motivating factor really uh
really really solid stuff
right there meanwhile by the way you
know we are
it is incredible to see how the media
have completely flipped on law
enforcement they flip back and forth on
law enforcement so here's my opinion
law enforcement ought to be transparent
people who attack law enforcement ought
to go to jail
the media's perspective is it sort of
depends on who you are
it sort of depends on what your
political motivation is
so if you are a black person who is
resisting arrest and is shot by the
police
then the police must inherently be
racist and it is indicative of the
entire police structure
which is structurally biased if you're
actually a babit
and you're a white lady who's attempting
to invade the capitol building and
you're shot to death
then anybody who wants to know the full
information
is bad anybody who wants to know the
full information is a problem we still
don't know the identity of the officer
who shot ashley babbitt by the way
again i understand the safety predicate
for that we don't want the officer to be
threatened
and in fact ashley david should not have
been climbing through a window at the
capitol building in an attempt to do
harm she should have not been doing that
that was a criminal activity
i'm just noting the complete double
standard with regard to behavior of the
police
and the and the way the left treats the
cops in these particular
scenarios all of which is to say when it
comes down to it
the left requires january 6th they
require january 6th but if they think
that the election of 2022 or 2024 is
going to be
about january 6th as opposed to the
left's radical asymmetric it is from
symmetric
political push to radicalize everything
every institution of our society
up to and including the indoctrination
of small children that's not going to
work
so watch for them to continue pushing it
but it is going to be unsuccessful in
the long run because
it turns out too many americans are
paying attention now
which is a very good thing all right
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywear.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel wydowsky
producer bradford carrington host
producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show